Would any remaining
passengers for flight KA29,
please make their
way to gate B15.
Good morning, everyone, this is
Captain Robin Allen speaking.
Flight time today
6 hours, 54 minutes.
Stay in your seats!
Get down now!
Operation has commenced.
Phones, tablets.
Plane is under control.
You need to see this.
Plane veered off course.
Someone is calling for help.
You got family? Loved ones?
We’ve got one job
to do right now.
Just get through it for them.
I got a message from the plane.
Dad says incident onboard.
What exactly does
your dad do for a living?
It’s difficult to explain.
Sam is the best at handling it.
Handling what?
The negotiation.
There are 200 people
on this flight.
If they try something,
and then this plane goes down.
I don’t get home to my family.
Let me make you an offer.
I’ve been handed demands.
If it’s all going wrong
in the first hour,
imagine the next 6.
We need to get a message
to the whole plane.
We just need to be ready.
There’s other stuff going down.
Five passengers on that
plane do not exist.
It's a network running
all across Europe.
To them, we’re an
incoming missile.
It’s either us or them.
And I can tell you it’s
not going to be us.
♪♪